hey guys welcome to another video by
simply learn in this video we will learn
about what is typescript
let's look at what's in it for you in
today's session
we'll first start with understanding
what is typescript
followed by which we will look at why
should we use typescript then we will
look at the difference between
typescript versus javascript
then we will look at some of the
important features of typescript
followed by which we will look at the
applications of typescript and
proceeding further we will look at
advantages of using typescript and
disadvantages of using typescript
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon so you never
miss an update from simply learn
what is typescript
is object oriented and strongly type
programming language which is superset
of javascript
typescript code is converted to
javascript which can be executed
anywhere javascript is supported in a
browser or node.js and any other
application
hipscript was designed by anders
hegelsberg at microsoft the limitations
of javascript for the development of
large-scale application at the microsoft
and among its external customers led to
the creation of typescript
due to the difficulty of working with
the complicated javascript code there
was demand for custom tooling to make
developing javascript components easier
typescript is javascript with some
additional features
to support a strong interaction with
your editor typescript adds additional
syntax to javascript
typescript is a scripting language that
understands javascript and uses type
inference to provide powerful
capabilities without the need for
additional code
why typescript compilation javascript is
an interpreted language there is no need
to compile it as a result it must be run
to ensure that it is genuine if there is
an error that implies you write all the
code to find out an output
as a result you will have to spend hours
looking for the faults in the code so
error checking is provided via the
typescript transpiler if typescript
detects any syntax mistakes it will
compile the code and generate
compilation errors this aids in the
detection of mistakes prior to the
execution of the script
typescript provides an optional type
system for javascript code when a client
doesn't have a value for a parameter he
can pass a null optional arguments are
features of typescript we can declare
some arguments in the function optional
by utilizing optional parameter features
so that the client is not necessary to
supply a value to optional parameters
strong static typing javascript does not
have a powerful static typing system
does the tls typescript comes with an
optional static typing and type
inference system the tls that is a
typescript language service can deduce
the type of variable defined with no
type based on its value
supports object oriented programming
such as classes interfaces inheritance
and other object oriented programming
principles are supported by typescript
typescript supports type definitions
existing javascript libraries can use
typescript type definitions external
javascript libraries are defined in
typescript definition files
as a result these libraries can be
included in typescript code
now let us look at the difference
between typescript versus javascript
typescript is an object oriented
programming language
whereas javascript is a scripting
language
and typescript supports static typing
whereas javascript does not support
static typing
errors can be found and corrected during
compile time
in javascript errors can be found only
during the runtime as it is an
interpreted language
there is a concept for es3 es4 es5 and
es6 in typescript whereas no support for
compiling additional es3 es4 es5 or as6
features in javascript
functions can have optional parameters
in typescript whereas this feature is
not possible in javascript
converted into javascript code to be
understandable for browsers in
typescript in javascript this can
directly be used in browsers
in typescript proper build setup is
required for static type definitions
no build setup is required in javascript
now let us look at the features of
typescript
typescript supports other javascript
libraries typescript is a new microsoft
language that is highly typed superset
of javascript with support for object
oriented programming and other current
features like decorators
because browsers and nodes comprehend
javascript typescript compiles to
javascript
typescript is portable typescript is
cross browser cross device and cross
platform it can run in any environment
that supports javascript typescript
unlike its competitors does not require
dedicated virtual machine or a specific
runtime environment to run typescript is
superset of javascript
it's a strong syntactical superset of
javascript with the addition of optional
static typing
typescript is a large scale application
development language that transcompiles
to javascript
typescript is static and typescript is
object oriented language
when a client doesn't have a value for a
parameter he can personal optional
arguments are a feature of typescript
when it comes to object oriented
programming with javascript javascript
shines because of the class keyword it
makes object oriented programming look
quite similar to programming in other
object oriented languages like c sharp
or java
applications of typescript
typescript can be used to develop
javascript applications for both
client-side and server-side execution
typescript can be deployed instead of
javascript language since it adds more
features and gives error directly with
the code
typescript is used for building large
scale application for enterprises
advantages of typescript
highlights error at the compilation time
during the time of development
in typescript it runs on any browser or
javascript engine
typescript has a namespace concept by
defining a module
typescript support strongly typed or
static typing
disadvantages of typescript
typescript takes a long time to compile
the code
typescript does not support abstract
classes
typescript has extra compilation step
for converting typescript into
javascript typescript has an overly
complicated typing system
so with that we have reached the end of
this video i hope you liked the video
thank you for watching keep learning and
stay tuned to simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here